foreign
I wanted to talk to you about
the average American Kitchen has a lot
of kitchen utensils
what do you think are three things in
the kitchen that are completely obsolete
if you're eating an ancestrally
consistent diet I just want to hear him
talk about air fryers mostly
you don't need a toaster yeah right yes
yeah for sure yeah
um I'm just thinking of the the Airbnb
that I stayed in they had a Keurig so
I'm not a fan yeah yeah I mean even if
you're drinking coffee you're not going
to make Keurig coffee no yep
um I'm trying to think what else was in
there that we didn't use I mean there's
a lot of little utensils also that we
didn't use I mean I basically use a fork
and a knife and a spatula to flip things
on the grill and some plates and
everything else is kind of
obsolete so what's essential to you is
either a cast iron pan or maybe uh
what's the stainless steel pan yeah yeah
um and some sort of spatula yeah and you
obviously are avoiding anything with
Teflon or non-stick coating so anything
with Teflon you could consider obsolete
absolutely yeah why is that
again we're back to pfas we're back to
Forever chemicals parafluoroalkylated
compounds in the Teflon
chips off it ends up in the food we know
that Teflon also aerosolizes when you
cook on it so oh yeah so I added I
started to unpack the Airbnb a little
bit when I got to the one in Los Angeles
and I opened the cabinet and before I
come to this one I was talking to the
property management company and I said
do you have nice pots and pans because I
I really need to cook on stainless steel
they said oh yeah we've got good stuff I
know and I open the thing and it's all
Teflon I texted them right away this is
not gonna stand man this is this is not
cool and he said oh it's they must be
somewhere else and we found that they
for some reason the cleaners had moved
the nice set of cookware to another
closet in the house that I had to go
find and then you know some sequester
that's a shitty cookware somewhere else
but I I was I was freaking out a little
bit I was thinking I was going to have
to go to Crate and Barrel and buy my own
pan because I will not cook on Teflon so
what's up with the stainless steel
versus the cast iron so cast iron I
think it's just the the cast iron is
going to hold the heat better yeah and
it's just gonna be a better cook like in
terms of like the way that it's going to
cook the steak I think if you get a
really good cast iron it might hold the
heat in a certain way it's just it's
kind of high level Chef stuff I got you
so it's not like the iron's bad for you
or anything from a cast iron it's more
about the way that it holds the Heat I
think it's only going to add a little
bit of iron to your food if you're
someone who does have iron overload you
might want to avoid a cast iron yeah
yeah but again it's minimal it's small
small amounts yeah some people benefit
from cast iron if they have low iron so
we get rid of the toaster we get rid of
anything that has a non-stick coating on
it one might say anything that's plastic
as well right we're definitely getting
rid of the dishwasher oh okay we'll talk
about that yeah so there's actually been
some studies looking at
the people are not going to like this
there's there's like a biofilm that
happens on your dishes that's probably
beneficial for humans we this kind of
wraps into this idea of a hygiene
hypothesis and that we're overly clean
as humans and we're probably meant to
have a little bit of dirt and a little
bit of biofilm on our utensils and so it
finds that people who use dishwashers
have a less diverse gut Flora I believe
so yeah I don't like dishwashers because
I think philosophically I just want to
clean the dishes and then put them away
I don't like putting things somewhere
where they're just sitting and I can't
use them I just don't like dishwashers
totally agree I've I've never used a
dishwasher I've lived in houses now
because growing up like we didn't have a
dishwasher growing up in the house so
like why would I and then I move into a
place that has a dishwasher I'm like I
don't get like this is how I wash my
dishes so I like the fact that you use
baking soda and use vinegar to I assume
to clean your countertops as well so you
don't require so maybe another obsolete
object or all of these fragrant filled
cleaners that are all over the house and
they're doing the same thing they can
potentially disrupt the gut microbiome
by sterilizing everything and hormones
but they have xenoestrogens parabens
phthalates neurologic disruptions yeah
it's crazy how many of these things I
mean you think about what you put in the
dishwasher most people are washing their
dishes in a very fragrant blue purple or
orange gel that probably isn't great for
humans just like they're washing their
clothes in a blue purple or orange gel
that isn't great for humans and I never
wanted to do that so it's yeah it's a
very strange thing and I really for me
it's actually satisfying to just
sit and wash the dishes there's like Zen
Proverbs about that make sure your rice
bowl is clean yes I'm assuming
microwaves are something you get rid of
as well I think that without knowing all
of the microwave research to a deep
level I just why would I ever use a
microwave I'd rather either eat the food
cold or heat it you know yeah eat it
when you're when you're ready to eat it
heat it when I'm ready to eat it and I
would never stand in front of a
microwave because I'm sure some of that
radiation is leaking out yeah by the way
tweet that heat it when you're ready to
eat it
are you hitting on me did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free